[Music]
time now for the friendzone we bring out
one of our friends from here at Fox on
to the show tonight
our old friend Brett Barry hosts special
report he's not just a newsman and a
political expert he is also a history
buff and a best-selling author he's got
a new book out out tomorrow actually
it's called three days in Moscow Ronald
Reagan and the fall of the Soviet empire
Bret Baier joins us tonight hey Bret
hey thanks Rob man Doug Brinkley one of
the most famous maybe the most famous
Reagan historian calls this book quote
one of the best and most essential books
ever written about Ronald Reagan that's
I've been yours blurb no it's it's it's
an amazing three days you've sort of
boiled down the pivotal moment to three
days what three days well it's the three
days of the fourth summit between Reagan
and Gorbachev where Reagan goes to
Moscow and he meets with Gorbachev
they're finalizing the nuclear arms
treaty but he also gives an uncovered
kind of an overlook for the most part
speech to Moscow State University
students and takes QA from them we use
that three days to jump back and look at
how Reagan gets to this point and really
leads to the seminal moment of the Cold
War coming to an end the wall coming
down and communism really taking a hit
the whole world was changed soon after
them what did Reagan know about
communism of the Soviet Union that
others missed from the very beginning he
thought that communism was just not
going to make it and that it was
destined as he said in a speech for the
ash heap of history
he spoke about that for a long time even
back when he was president of the Screen
Actors Guild fighting communism in
Hollywood and you see that throughout
his life he holds that principle gives
some really standings
stinging speeches including calling the
Soviet Union the evil empire but when
Mikhail Gorbachev comes up he sees in
Gorbachev someone that he can negotiate
with and it was tough in some of those
summits we have a lot of behind the
scenes new nuggets interviews
interviewed Secretary of State George
Shultz who is a national treasure
at his age remembers meetings like they
were yesterday some oral histories that
really had never been dug into about
behind the scenes and it really paints a
picture of how the Cold War comes to the
end interesting I have an office next
year so I know you've been working on
this book for a while what did you come
away thinking about Reagan did it change
your view of him yeah I think at the
time he was underappreciated you know
there were a lot of books looking back a
favorably to Reagan but this is more
reporting on history and some of the
behind-the-scenes moments and in
speeches for example when he gives that
speech in Berlin at the Brandenburg Gate
tear down this wall mr. Gorbachev there
were about 10 people inside the White
House who did not want him to say that
the State Department took it out of the
speech multiple times he kept on putting
it back in and he went to that speech
with it not in and he we had a
conversation in the limo on the way to
the wall where he turns to an aide and
says you know what the guys that stayed
are gonna kill me but this is the right
thing to do and he puts it back in now
that speech happens on June 12 1987 we
have a big summit coming up June 12th in
Singapore and I didn't plan it that way
but there is some synergy there in
history can you imagine being the guy
who took out the phrase tear down this
wall
I hope history treats him badly this
book it's out tomorrow the review these
are not just a normal blurb so you get
your friends say oh great book by two
copies these are like these are
unbelievable and they're from historians
so it's extra impressive I'm reading it
this weekend repair thank you great to
see you Congrats nice talker appreciate